Dragonball has captured our hearts and
at least made us imagine how life would
be if we had superpowers the franchise
is still alive and continues to amaze us
with the unlimited powers of the Saiyans
and now the gods of destruction but this
list today will be about the 10 biggest
Dragon Ball characters who have appeared
ever since the first Dragon Ball series
err decades ago we won't be including
super Shenron on the list as he is
bigger than a multiverse but we do have
three dragons here so check out the list
and let us know your thoughts number 10
King Yemma he is the king of all ogres
and the one who judges the dead all
those who passed away make up a line of
souls that leads to his office where he
decides whether soul goes to heaven or
hell compared to the other augers King
Yemma is on a different color as he has
a beard he has a helmet with two horns
and his colossal in size he is more than
40 feet tall or 12 meters in height and
it's the first giant character we see in
the series number 9
gen ember first form he is the main
antagonist from the 12th Dragon Ball
film Dragon Ball Z fusion reborn J
number was created when a young over who
was put in charge of cleaning the soul
cleanser neglects the machine this
caused all of the negative energy from
the machine to explode and transform the
ogre into gen ember in his first form he
is gigantic and a bit taller than King
Yemma
and he would have been around 50 feet
tall or 15 metres number eight giant
Bergamo the next on the list appears in
Dragon Ball super and as a character
from the nineteen universe Bergamo is
described as a smooth-talking
egotistical and honorable fighter
Bergamo is the tallest and the most
muscular of the tree of danger where
gamma can grow to a gigantic size via
damage absorption for each hit he
receives he grows larger in size where
gamos potential power is not endless
however but at the peak of his height he
was easily more than 60 feet tall or 18
metres
number seven lots luck this next entry
is from the animated movie Dragon Ball Z
loft slot and it's anime Qian antagonist
it is explained that he is one of the
super namekians and was sent to planets
luck as a baby to escape the extinction
that was about to ravish Namek as he
matured them evil in his heart begins to
overwhelm his character thanks to a rare
mutation unique to namekians however he
can transform into a giant namekian slot
form that puts his height at around 21
meters or nearly 70 feet tall number six
the oozaru how can we have a list of
Dragon Ball characters without the
Saiyans news aru or the giant ape which
is a giant antropomorphic monkey-like
creature that Saints can transform into
at the full moon to increase their
already formidable strength the great
apes can vary a lot in size depending on
the same and their powers Gohan's great
ape would have been around fifty feet
tall
while Vegeta's gulen great ape from
Dragon Ball GT was more than 80 feet
tall or 24 meters number 5 Anna Lhasa
this next entry is called acne Lhasa or
Anna Lhasa and is a gigantic humanoid
with no visible nose and solid pink eyes
with no pupils its body has whiter
layers on a skin on its neck in head
shoulders and chest area in the center
of its forehead is a large red gem which
acts as an energy core
it was truly monstrous in size standing
anywhere between 80 to a hundred feet
tall or between 24 and 30 meters number
four here udag on hiruta gan is a
towering behemoth with a vaguely
humanoid appearance its head is shaped
like a human skull and it possesses a
long tail after metamorphosis this
creature gains shoulder blades horns and
insectoid wings he is the main
antagonist in Dragon Ball Z wrath of the
Dragon he has an enormous phantom margin
that destroys everything and kills
anyone in its path more than twice the
size of Lords luck
it was between a hundred and a hundred
twenty feet tall all between 30 and 37
meters number 3 Shenron now we come to
the dragon's Shenron is shown with brown
antlers sharp teeth green scaly skin red
eyes four toes on each foot a long
serpentine body long flowing whiskers a
lungs now crescent-shaped nostrils and
flowing green hair on his cheek wow he
is an Eastern dragon who's kind our
benevolent and sacred in Oriental
mythologies his kind are good at heart
but as a strong dragon Shenron has an
aggressive temper and his impatient his
size is difficult to ascertain as it
differs every time he is summoned but
one can assume that he is easily over
500 meters at maximum or 1,600 feet
number 2 / unga-bunga is much more
brutal looking than Shenron with a
heavily muscled upper body with large
pectoral muscles shoulders and
well-defined apse
haha instead of looking snake-like an
appearance like Shenron das / Unga
appears to be more alligator like baring
great resemblance to the Naga a group of
serpentine deities in Hindu and Buddhist
mythology he is the namekian dragon and
can grant three wishes
Muruga is definitely larger than Shenron
but around the same length around 1600
feet of 500 meters as general snake-like
body is deceiving number one ultimate
Shenron as said earlier we have excluded
super Shenron who's the size of the
multiverse so the top of the list goes
to ultimate Shenron who is the third
eternal dragon introduced to us ultimate
Shenron can only be summoned by using
particular collection of Dragon Balls
the Black Star Dragon Balls in this case
while Shenron and piranha are both
comparable in size to a large skyscraper
ultimate Shenron is so lashed and his
head alone is roughly the size of
commies look out if the lookout was
around 100 meters in diameter then
imagine its total length it would have
been at least 10 kilometers or 33,000
feet and so with this we come to the end
of the list
do you like share and subscribe for more
related content and smashed a
notification bell